hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
maximizing tumor microenvironment
analysis for tills from limited patient
samples
i am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrius and brought to you
by miltoni biotek
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
all of your questions will be answered
via email following the broadcast today
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentations
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
cesar evarusto group leader r d tumor
immunology at miltoni biotech
dr evaristo you may now begin your
presentation
welcome you all to this webinar entitled
every cell matters how to maximize tumor
microenvironment analysis from limited
patient samples
i will start by giving a short
introduction followed by identifying
some of the challenges faced when
conducting cancer research and how we
developed workflows to overcome those
challenges i will then zoom in on some
of those
workflows in detail some of the tools we
use for sample preparation magnetic
enrichment and analysis of the
populations of interest
the immune system has the capacity to
eliminate tumors
mutated
antigens can be released from tumor
cells and introduce
induce an immune response in which dcs
will activate tumor-specific t-cells
these t-cells then migrate through the
blood vessels into the tumor sites where
they recognize and kill the tumor cells
for the most part this is an effective
process
however in every single cancer patient
at least one of these steps has failed
immunotherapy has proven clinical
efficacy and tremendous potential in
multiple cancers but even patients who
experience clinical benefits from these
new agents often achieve only partial
responses such that additional work is
necessary to improve immunotherapeutic
strategies
as this figure illustrates solid tumors
are complex tissues not only are they
comprised of proliferating tumor cells
but are supported by a plethora of
thermal cells that participate in
functions such as tissue remodeling and
new antigenesis including many different
immune cells
all these cell populations are in
constant communication and influence
each other's activity function and fate
it's becoming increasingly clear that a
comprehensive analysis of the tumor
microenvironment is key to understand
the dynamics of
the anti-tumor immune response
in our case we're interested in
phenotyping tumor cells fibroblasts
endothelial cells t cells b cells and
myeloid cells
and sequencing tumor cell mutations
identifying new antigens in tumor
specific t and b cell clones
however
to do this we are dependent on the
availability of tumor material
this brings us to the challenges
routinely faced when planning and
performing experiments in cancer
research
most of the tumor samples from patients
we get weigh between 0.4 and 1 gram
after dissociation
we get between 4 and 20 million live
cells
it turns out that the re the frequency
of tills or tumor-infiltrating
leukocytes in the tumor can be very
reduced as illustrated by this graph on
the left
i calculated in this table on the right
the absolute number of t b and myeloid
cells that we would obtain from a tumor
with 20 million live cells containing
the average frequency of observed
we that we have observed
among our samples
we'd get 1 million t-cells 200 000 b
cells in 1.8 million myeloid cells
however
if we have to divide our dissociated
tissue in multiple samples to
individually analyze the different cell
populations we would
waste the majority of ourselves
to prevent that we develop tools and
workflows that allow extracting the
maximum amount of information from
limited material while minimizing the
experimental time and work for in
workload
i will start by briefly summarizing
examples of our strategy and then zoom
in on specific portions of it
it all starts with the resection or
biopsy of the tumor sample
the tissue is stored and transported in
tissue storage solution
upon arrival a small tissue section is
collected for future immunochemistry
analysis
the remainder is dissociated and we take
a small sample to identify and quantify
the immune cell populations
we can then isolate
t cells
using halle cd4 cdh till microbead kits
these new reagents can be released from
the cell surface after positive
selection of the cells of interest
the isolated t cells can then be used
for phenotypical analysis
undergo further magnetic removal of dead
cell
in order to obtain cells with high
viability which is required for
downstream applications such as single
cell immune profiling and rna sequencing
will even be used for example for
further magnetic subset enrichment
followed by in vitro expansion and
further analysis
the negative friction from the t-cell
isolation can also be used
the
realise cd45 till micro beads kits
can be used to isolate the rest of the
tumor infiltrating leukocytes
after magnetic release these cells can
be further used to isolate for example
myeloid cells or b cells which can then
be used for downstream applications such
as phenotype culture or sequencing
the negative fraction from the cd45
isolation can also be used for tumor
cell enrichment
this is performed using a negative
selection kit and the tumor cells can
then be used for multiple downstream
applications such as next generation
sequencing a new epitope prediction
phenotype culture or establishment of
patient-derived xenograft models
finally
the positive fraction from the tumor
cell enrichment step other cells of
interest can be recovered such as cancer
associated fibroblasts which can be
phenotyped
i will focus the rest of this webinar
on a subset of these workflows
additional multi-new webinars
detail the performance and downstream
applications of the other workflows
i will do that by showcasing some of the
analysis we performed on one particular
sample
from an ovarian cancer patient
most of the data going forward was
generated from a single tumor sample
additional supporting data used to
characterize the performance of
particular tools will be clearly
identified
in this particular experiment we were
contacted in the middle of the afternoon
with information that an ovarian
carcinoma sample has been rejected from
patients
the tumor sample was stored in max
tissue storage solution and shipped to
us overnight
this solution has been developed to
allow optimized storage of fresh organ
and tissue samples
it has been tested and validated on a
variety of human and mouse tissues
including tumors lung heart brain spleen
skin
kidney and skeletal muscle
the graph on the left
shows the frequency
of cells per gram of tissue recovered
after storage in different solutions
for 48 hours at 4 degrees or room
temperature as compared with the fresh
tissue on the column on the right
and this graph
shows the viability of the cells in the
same conditions
as you can see tissues stored in mac
station storage solution at 4 degrees
maintain original cellular yield and
viability even after 48 hours with no
induction of apoptosis or increase in
necrosis
and no selectivation or influence on
marker expression
the next morning we used our automated
dissociator in our optimized tumor
dissociation kit to generate a single
cell suspension
using these tools
automated dissociation of multiple
samples can be done in parallel
it combines both mechanical and
enzymatic treatment for efficient
dissociation
this means the disruption of
extracellular matrix in cell adhesion
components without destroying the
integrity of the cell membrane while
simultaneously preserving the cell
surface epitopes
the interest of optimized enzymatic
dissociation can be showcased in this
example just doing a mechanical
dissociation will result in the loss of
cell populations which are closely
attached to the tumor cells such as
tumor reactive t cells
using the tumor association kits will
enable the identification of these rare
cell populations
furthermore we do in-house control of
the quality of the enzymes used and the
tumor dissociation kit was optimized for
epitope preservation we tested over 200
epitopes the vast majority of which was
not affected by our enzyme composition
i'm not expecting you to be able to read
this but this list of tested epitopes
can be accessed on our website
after dissociation we took a small
sample to identify and quantify the
immune cell populations using our age
color immunophenotyping kit
here i am showing the plots with the
gating strategy
after excluding dead cells and doublets
we gauge on cd45 positive leukocytes
from those we use a morphology gate to
exclude small debris in large tumor
cells we can then identify cd14 positive
macrophages and from the cd14 low
population we plot cd19 versus cd3 to
identify b cells
from the non-b cell gate
we plot cd16 cd56 in the same channel
against side scatter to identify
neutrophils and eosinophils
from the site scatter low gate we plot
cd16 in cd5 t6 against cd3 to identify
in k cells t cells and cd3 positive cd56
positive cells
finally from the t cell gate we plot cd4
versus cd8 to identify our major t cell
populations
we can then quantify the frequency of
the major leukocyte populations in the
tumor and it becomes quite obvious that
the frequencies of each of the
individual populations is quite low
because these cells are so often found
in low frequencies we develop new
reagents for the magnetic isolation of t
cells specifically from the tumor
based on the new release technology
briefly
the release technology relies on
recombine recombinantly engineered low
affinity antibody fragments that are
multimeterized in the realist complex
cells are labeled with these
biotinylated complexes in anti-biotin
microbeads
the target cells are then retained on a
column placed on a magnet
while non-target cells flow through
the target cells are then eluded and the
microbeads are removed resulting in
beet-free cells that can be used for
second magnetic labeling in isolation
for certain applications the release
complex can also be removed resulting in
label-free cells
using these new reagents we were
consistently able to quickly isolate
tumor infiltrating leukocytes with high
purity and directly use them for
analysis or because of the additional
flexibility provided by the hayali
system we have a world of possibilities
for isolation of specific populations
we can purify t-rex from tumors
combining really cd4-2 with ca25
microbeads we can generate high
viability tills for rna-seq using dead
cell removal kit after t cell isolation
we can isolate tumor-resident memory t
cells isolate tumor-specific versus
bystander cells we can isolate untouched
gamma delta t cells and so on
we isolated t cells from our dissociated
ovarian carcinoma sample using reality
cd4 cd8 still microbead kit
in addition to this
we also have available really cd4 cd8
and cd3 micro beat kits for tumors t
cell
and we will soon also have the realist
cd45 till microbead kit available
using these brand new reagents we were
able to quickly isolate tills with high
purities
on the top row you can see the frequency
of cd3 positive cells among live single
lymphocyte-sized
cells in the bulk sample as compared to
after isolation on the bottom row
we were able to achieve over 92 percent
purity of tumor infiltrating t cells
from our ovarian carcinoma sample
after magnetic enrichment of our cells
of interest we are now ready for
analysis
this is done
using affinity antibodies and analyzed
on the max quant a fully automated flow
cytometer
the affinity antibodies are genetically
engineered to enhance reproducibility
and eliminate bias
all antibodies have one universal igg-1
isotype which reduces the complexity of
the experimental planning and a mutated
fc region that eliminates seo receptor
binding mediated background
using magnetically isolated t cells from
the ovarian tumor sample greatly
facilitated
flow cytometry analysis
having highly enriched cells of interest
reduces the number of total events we
need to acquire for meaningful analysis
of rare subpopulations resulting in
shorter acquisition time reduced
background and cleaner populations
in this example we interrogated the
expression of pd1 cd39 tim three and
four one bb
among cd4 t cells on the top row and
among city h t cells on the bottom row
in addition we were interested in
performing rna-seq into immune profiling
t and b cells infiltrating this tumor
sample
require preserved analect of the
dissociated tumor
and at a later time point we thought our
sample and remove the dead cells using
the dead cell removal kit
we then used the really cd4 cdh-2
microbeads to isolate t cells for single
cell tcr sequencing in rna-seq
from the negative fraction we isolated b
cells in plasma cells for single cell
bcr sequencing
this way we could use the majority of t
cells for the t cell analysis and the
majority of b cells for b cell analysis
we use the 10x platform which can
generate up to 10 000 single cell gems
per sample
so a direct effect of magnetically
isolating the cells of interest is that
we greatly increase the frequency of
single cell tcrs in bcrs on our sample
as you can see in this table
in these graphs i am displaying in the
x-axis the 50 or 25 more represented
clonotypes in t or b cells respectively
and in the y-axis the number of cells
that express that particular clonotype
in the isolated sample
as you can see we were able to identify
several chronotypes that were
represented multiple times in the
isolated samples
in contrast
several of those chronotypes would have
gone unnoticed when we analyzed the bulk
samples for example a clonal type that
was present in 28 t cells in the
isolated sample was only present in
three cells in the bulk sample
on the b cells we were able to identify
one chronotype represented 120 cells
from magnetically isolated b cells but
was only found in four cells in the bulk
sample
these results highlight the degree to
which magnetic isolation can improve the
resolution of single cell rna-seq and
immune profiling
with this workflow we were able to
identify and quantify tumor-infiltrating
immune populations
isolate multiple cell populations for
downstream analysis
characterize phenotypically the isolated
populations and increase the resolution
of single cell rna-seq and immune
profiling of cells of interest
however in order to completely
characterize the tumor microenvironment
it may be useful to access the spatial
distribution of different cell
populations in their phenotypes
in order to do that
before tumor dissociation we collected a
small tissue section and used our maxima
platform which allows the staining of
hundreds of markers in a single sample
it uses the principle of an iterative
staining process conducted by the maxima
imaging platform in a completely
automated manner
briefly this platform stains the sample
with the first specificity and acquires
a fluorescence microscope image
the staining is then erased
the sample is stained with a second
specificity and the second image is
collected
this cycle can be repeated hundreds of
times in a fully automated way
as an example
i am showing a section from our initial
ovarian cancer
sample
with a region rich in tumor ios in the
top right corner
characterized by expression of afcam and
t-span h
in a stronghold region without tumor
cells
in the following slides we will keep
epcamp staining in red tried entertained
tumor cells and the indicated marker
will be displayed in white
looking at cd45 expression we can
appreciate that immune cells tend to
accumulate outside of the tumor area
we can locate the macrophages using cd14
expression for example
td-30h identifies b cells
plasma cells can be identified by cd
138 expression
pd3 expression identifies t cells
of which the majority are cd4 cells
consistent with our flow cytometry data
but also we can find our cd8 t cells
and we can further characterize
phenotypically the t cell
in this case with the expression of the
costume
co-stimulatory molecule cd27
or cd28
41bb
icos
but also markers that correlates with
tissue resident memory t cells like cd69
and cd103
expression of chemokine receptors can
also be assessed like cxcl cxcr3
we can identify cells that express pdl1
for negatively regulating t selectivity
and the expression of immune checkpoints
like ctla4
pd1
and tim3
we can even identify which cells were
actively
proliferating using t67 staining
in this case unfortunately this
indicates that tumor cells are the ones
proliferating in this sample
in summary i showed you here today new
workflows that allow the complete
characterization of the tumor
microenvironment
these start with tissue preservation
during shipping with tissue storage
solution
automated tissue dissociation with
optimized enzymatic mix
in identification and quantification of
tumor infiltrating immune populations
by implementing magnetic enrichment
steps we are able to
analyze multiple distinct populations
while minimizing the loss of limited
material and enhance the phenotypic
characterization of the isolated cell
populations
using the new realist technology we can
perform consecutive enrichment of
dedicated
subpopulations
and have complete flexibility for
studying several cell populations from
just one sample
in addition magnetic enrichment results
in increased
resolution of single cell rna-seq and
immune
profiling of cells of interest
finally
with maximum imaging platform we can
study the spatial distribution of
different self-populations in their
phenotypes within the tumor
microenvironment
using these workflows it becomes
feasible to fully embrace the complexity
of the tumor microenvironment
i would like to acknowledge my team and
all my colleagues at milton biotech that
made it possible to put together these
workflows as well as our collaborators
at the university of guttingham bonn and
cologne for providing material and
testing our workflows offsite
thank you dr evaristo for your
informative presentation and for your
time today
we would also like to thank labruz and
our sponsor miltoni biotech for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
all questions submitted today and during
the on-demand period will be addressed
by our speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrints will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye